[Music]
I want to thank you because of you I
have access to supportive academic
resources and conducive study spaces all
over campus Thank You donors it's
because of you that I get to study with
some of the most amazing professors in
the world like Marlena
and do groundbreaking research and I get
to teach amongst the best students in
the world and conduct groundbreaking
research thank you because of you I
manage my stress and stay healthy by
participating in group workouts in
classes thank you
[Music]
because of you I get hands-on experience
in research labs and access to equipment
across campus because of you we can
participate in student organizations and
service ships that matter to us because
of you we can change the world thank you
because of you I can make magic happen
every time the curtain rises thank you
because of you we can create the future
of technology thank you because of you I
have an advantage thanks to CMU
exclusive job fairs I've had access to
awesome opportunities in my field
[Music]
thank you thanks thank you thanks
you